this is a production of Cornell
University welcome you to the
restoration ecology 2017 cohorts
presentation of their class project and
one of the objects of the project is to
expose the students to experience or
learning a situation where you know you
try once you fail you try twice you fail
and then by the third or fourth time you
finally get it figured out how you
actually should do it and what looks
really good on a blackboard or
whiteboard in a classroom situation
changes very rapidly when you are in hip
waders and you are in mud maybe up to
your knees and say well maybe I can only
do one of these sample sites or maybe I
can only collect one kind of sample what
we're looking at right now is one of
many drone over flights that we did of
its it's called treeman Lake or Lake
Freeman it's more like Tremont lake and
marsh complex this is the dam and so we
were we were able to do a number of very
interesting things over the past several
months including these drilling over
points and we spent a lot of time
canoeing around and sampling the
vegetation and collecting soil samples
and so forth so before we actually get
started I'm going to encourage everyone
to grab a bite to eat if you haven't
already done so Aaron anybody still need
lunch
okay okay this is this is the class Wow
they look a little bit different than
they do at 8:30 on a Tuesday morning
it's it's it's really good to see
everyone all of you and all of them and
check this out there are two members of
the class standing in the middle of a
little Peninsula on the marsh so I'm
going to turn things over to class
members right now and Audrey oh okay
Audrey was our TA this year good job
keeping me honest and making sure that
we didn't leave things behind we didn't
lose any students so Audrey you wanna do
your introduction in there thank you all
very much for coming today this is
exciting we spent a fall semester
working together a lot and it's
wonderful to see you come together so
thank you I'd like to begin with some
history so starting around 1930 the
Civilian Conservation Corps but in the
dam and what was buttermilk cream
creating like treatment and so slowly
over the years the area has been
familiar with settlement just like the
southern end of the Finger Lakes they've
been filling the segment ever since the
glaciers and so they've Truman is really
a community asset it provides ecosystem
services like sediment mitigation and -
speak louder
of course the sediment is trapped via
the dam and go down
or like how you got this is really
helpful to the community over time the
area has change from glacial to Creek to
link and now we see it slowly
transitioning into a wetland marsh the
question now is what we want the system
to do what it can do for us what we
would like when talking with the New
York State Park Department we decided to
address a couple of important issues for
managing the area first and foremost we
wanted to estimate the depth of the
water and the volume of sediment behind
the dam to do that we outfitted a canoe
with the hand made a symmetry device and
we put on waders and we use 1989 Maps to
do these calculations you see some of
these calculations later it's pretty
exciting we also wanted to adjust the
invasives on the site and so the state
was looking into getting funding for
this and we wanted to help so we put on
waders we grabbed the GPS we started
mapping where the Phragmites was and
where the maui was in doing this we
discovered that there was a large
diversity of that we didn't think would
be there because it looked like a
cattail Marsh we also wanted to address
environments on human health and so we
sampled for bacterial contaminants that
would be upstream and downstream of the
dam to see there any differences among
the results would be we also looked at
heavy metals and soils and methane in
the sediment and at the end of the day
we really wanted to recognize the
ecosystem services and the functions
that the site is currently providing and
we want to provide realistic options
that will help these functions continue
and so with help from community
management's some of which are cute
today
does a lot of great work we're excited
to present
so with that in mind thank you all for
coming because I'll hand it over to make
for the presentation that way all right
um thank you all for coming exciting
stuff this is our entire semester so a
lot of work in time would've went into
this for sure these are all the general
things were going to be going over today
in greater detail than Audrey mentioned
as Audrey mentioned the lake is was
built or the lake was built in 1930 by a
dam by the CCC for many years and
existed as a lake and it was important
to the beauty of the area and the beauty
of the recreation facility also
important to keeping sediment out of the
swimming pool downstream but over time
it filled up with sediment 16 acres
worth about and as it is now it looks
nothing like what it used to this is a
historical map
it used to be a stream and it was turned
into a lake by the dam within a BU some
years it is now wetland and what we want
to know is is the wetland really that
bad or does it provide similar ecosystem
services as a lake and the show changed
roberta factor lake or kept as a wetland
okay so some site characteristics these
are the positive aspects of the marsh
not all negative aspects it prevents
sediment from flowing into the swimming
area and with that sediment also fecal
coliforms it provides an ecosystem for a
variety of urban species and animal
species and it provides a different
aesthetic than the lake you saw the
video it is quite beautiful
but what we want to know is if it's
worthwhile in camping
I'll hand it off to Tommy who is on the
mapping team I prefer not to use the mic
can everyone hear me if I don't so
general overview is that Lake treatment
doesn't exist in limbo there's a pretty
large watershed contributing float to it
the lake hair is represented by that
tiny set of black points in the in the
top left corner and the watershed itself
is very large so this is a map of a
digital elevation model some very
amazing people have allowed us to have a
1 meter resolution medium which is what
we used along with curb number
calculations to delineate the watershed
so this is the EEM displaying elevation
and then this is a layer representing
curve numbers so high curve numbers mean
that there's low permeability in that
soil and vice versa
perv numbers and this is a function of
both soil type and land-use type so this
was used in conjunction with the EEM to
delineate the watershed this gives us a
little bit more information about what
kind of runoff lake treatment is
receiving so in yellow is agricultural
land use and that kind of represents the
hot spots where we might expect
problematic or enough to be contributing
to the lake using the hydrological
models from the EEM and storm runoff we
could model the general flow of streams
in the area and if you zoom in further
this coincided pretty accurately with
the path of water up until we get to
Lake treatment where there has been a
slight divergence as we would expect so
using all of that data and NRCC storm
information we calculated runoff for a
24 hour storm for various frequencies so
this is an example of a frequency
duration curve for a one year storm a
storm of intensity that we can expect to
see once every year we did this for
various frequencies up to a storm that
you would expect to see once every 500
years and these are the corresponding
runoffs
runoff rates that we would expect to see
at the dam point
it's a commonly accepted practice to
model climate change in the year 2050 by
multiplying existing precipitation rates
by a factor of 1.5 so these are the
flows that we can expect to see 50 years
from now or less than 50 years
20 seconds and then I'll hand it over to
Kevin he talked about comparison with
historic maps yeah so in this 1938
picture you can see the lake perfectly
has a lake and it's no Marsh included
but as time progresses you begin to see
the encroachment of in March of the
marsh which currently stands at ten
point eight nine acres of the original
about 13 to 16 acre footprint of Lake
treatment original treatment so then
using those maps which Susan Hoskins
directed us to we could see we could
look more closely at how the extent of
the lake has changed so this is a more
modern representation which is still
slightly bigger than the current extent
this is from the 1950s you can see that
the lake displayed is significantly
larger with emerging wetland and the
South depicted by those dots I don't
know if you can see them currently but
they're emerging and then this is from
1898 before the dam was constructed
we're not completely sure about how
accurate this is because of the
equipment that they had in the 1800s but
is the best estimate that we have and
you can see here that the lake falls in
this area and the elevation ranges from
940 feet to 920 and we use that
information to determine the slope while
modeling the historic elevation of the
stream so this is just a side-by-side
comparison and so our de M shows us the
elevation of the surface of water but
doesn't tell us what the elevation of
the underlying sediment is like so
Dustin and Jonas and I went out in a
canoe with of the chemistry device and
got all these data points representing
the depth of water at different points
in the lake
and we could interpolate those to come
up with the general surface of
underwater so we could subtract the
volume of water from the current lake
but then we also have to model the
historic stream because surprisingly
there were no de M s in the eighteen
hundred's so we did that I can talk more
about the methodology because it was
slightly involved but we basically just
raised everything to the highest
elevation sloped it and then dug out the
channel
well it's sorry a de M is a digital
elevation model so it's basically just
topo lines at a very high resolution so
then these are our estimates for the
current volume of water in the lake acre
feet it might be an easier measure to
think about the meter cubed so if you if
you part of a 63 acre area it would be
raised to like one foot in depth and an
acre is approximately one football field
in size so the annual deposition is
pretty high and we could expect the
sediment to fill up the lake in about
thirty years if current conditions
remain the same to reduce deposition
rate there are certain hotspots of
erosion upstream of the lake that we
could address we could also construct a
channel adjacent to the wetland to allow
the water to have a higher velocity
meaning that it would be depositing less
self and Kevin has identified areas of
erosion hotspots yeah based on the vote
of coefficients and the land use we can
see certain areas where agricultural
land and a bear era cultural and
contributes mostly or we we believe that
contributes mostly to the deposition of
sediment and so as these critical areas
upstream of the dam that we believe in
the state or somebody should really look
into into more depth about controlling
imitation so as a step to maybe
he long gate the amount of time we have
until he needs to be dredged or some
other measure to control for the
deposition of sediment so then stream
Bank analysis was conducted at various
sites upstream of the lake to determine
what the channel looks like without
human influence or without too much
human influence so we did this manually
with levels and meter sticks and we
found a general trapezoidal cross
sectional shape to the channel upstream
of the area and this is just two more
from other sites so based on the cross
sectional area and the slope of the of
the stream we determined that using the
Roskam classification for streams which
is kind of like both hydrological and
ecological it falls between c and b so
kind of an intermediate slope liable to
changes in meander shape the service is
provided by the current system with the
wetland as it is are that it's
potentially treating agricultural runoff
so we do have some water samples that we
tested but extensive water sampling
could give us a better idea of what this
is it serves as a flood control system
currently because it is essentially a
retention basin it allows us to control
flow downstream with the boards as the
park currently does and it provides a
unique wetland habitat the hydrological
risks are that there's rapid deposition
happening which leads to a reduction in
basin capacity so if we get used to it
serving as a flood retention Basin that
might change in time if we don't control
for erosion additionally it will mean
that the one who gets flooded
speak with me and that can be a habitat
change so our recommendations are two
codes to perhaps construct a channel
adjacent to the wetland from the
hydrological perspective a trapezoidal
cross section is what we recommend based
on upstream characteristics and to avoid
erosion of we have more detailed
measurements about what the site slope
ratio should be to avoid erosion we
recommend that the bed be lined with
cobbles and shingles so basically
layered rocks as you would naturally see
in such a stream because they have a
very high roughness coefficient Europe
expressed as Manning's and meaning that
they're more resistant to erosion but
even then for a channel to carry the
discharge from a two-year storm without
any erosion it would have to be very
dirty big the reason for that is because
erosion naturally occurs during such
storms I'm sure no one has seen a stream
during a very heavy storm not have some
amount of sediment suspended in it so
there are two ways to perhaps combat
that one is through wetland stream
complex where we direct flow from the
wetland into the channel through a
permeable embankment so we would
essentially have a weapon on one side
under channel adjacent to it and they're
sharing flow underneath the surface if
we make this embankment out of a
permeable material and that also
provides two different habitats it
allows for more riparian habitat on one
side and
and mosaic on the other side I'll now
hand it over to the methane team
hi everybody so as we've already talked
about a bunch there's a lot of sediment
that has accumulated behind the dam and
that has because of the texture of that
sediment and the amount of water behind
it has led to methanogens producing a
lot of methane it's a very anoxic
environment underneath the dam and that
means that well greenhouse gases would
normally be produced methane is produced
in this case instead of co2 and methane
is a much more powerful greenhouse gas
and the water in the reservoir that the
dam has created also acts as a barrier
not allowing the methane that is created
through the sediment and the microbes in
the sediment to be released
it keeps the bubbles down from the
pressure this is important to our
recommendations for the site because it
depends on whether the stakeholders
involved care about this as a potential
source of greenhouse gases if there's a
lot of methane that could be released it
would probably not be wise to allow the
water to drain out
so we wanted to test how much methane
was being produced in the wetland these
are those sites that we dredge from used
an excellent wrench and we threw out
around the dam I just wanted to point
out that these areas we think have more
running water and these areas have more
stagnant water or what to interpretation
so from each sample we took 20 grams and
put them into airtight mason jars that
we pumped out to oxygen and pumped in
nitrogen to create an anoxic environment
for nothing to be produced
we incubated it for a week and then used
gas chromatography to measure how much
methane was in the mason jars and after
that one week then we enriched the
samples with 2 grams of dry cattails
each to add some more carbon from Adana
chains we again took out the oxygen
replace it with nitrogen incubated it
for one week and then tested how much
methane was produced in that I'm just
going to use this one so I'll run
through some of the results real quick
so we have to roll samples here and then
we have as jasmine was talking about the
Umbridge samples where we had two grams
of cattails just to make a bit more
clear we have here so this is the
methane produced in each of the sampling
sheets out here and we have an average
so as we expected we see a higher
methane reduction in new group enriched
samples because we added a substrate
there so that was kind of what we
expected and as jasmine was saying as
well sample three and four where we
expect more running water running fruit
we wouldn't expect like high methane
production there was these two samples
here because we expected all the water
to come through here so a low
segmentation there or where we have one
two and five when we assisted well we
expect this to be more sediment
depositing here so what we wanted to do
was to calculate the methane produced by
the lake and the wetland area so we
found some numbers for the sediment
density and we made the assumption that
methane is already produced in the tops
and 10 centimeters of the lake because
below that we don't really have any
carbon source by the help of Joey yard
of the Department of Natural Resources
we calculated this and we got a methane
production per year to be 14 to 27
kilograms
yeah to put this in perspective we knew
that this guy and a cow can produce
around 58 to 144 kilograms of methane in
you so that means that one cow produced
two to ten times as much methane a year
and the lakes last wetlands again
consulting with Joey Abbott we looked at
the global wetland emission of methane
and these numbers are actually pretty
low when you look at the like a standard
or the average wetland methane
production so our recommendation would
definitely or we the methane production
in the wetlands lastly wouldn't be it
that big of a concern it's always a
concern of course but not as much yes as
it could be
I'll hand it over to benthic group
hi guys so we went out on September 30th
and we just went to collect back the
convert boots we did take up streams
inside we did eight downstream sites and
three sites in the lake but we are only
able to get member grids from one of
those legs in the lake which was
interesting to say the least and that's
some some of us kicking into the nets
we went out again on October 13 just
because we wanted more so maybe one more
sampling from ops upstream so we went to
four more sites off of comfort mode and
then we did some staining with Jeremy
who's in the conduit map it was very
helpful so this is just more of us in
the field it was an interesting time I
learned a lot about Indians so we
collected 199 invertebrate species were
identified by family 16 families of
invertebrates were identified and these
are four drawings of what what they were
so yeah the template turbulently peptide
you made it and then we did four species
of fish so we wanted to we wanted to
like make sense of what all this means
so he did that
HDMI and Andrea miser is essentially the
Anna vertebrates ability to withstand
like pollution so like you lower your
age BMI the less the less resistant you
are like potion so you kind of want your
your numbers to be about as close to
zero as possible because that kind of is
indicative that your stream is pretty
not as pollutant so yes or even that
calculation
and so we divided it in terms of
upstream pool downstream pool you know
upstream fo now some FL and our entire
side is about a four so it's moderately
polluted I don't think it's too much to
be worried about one thing that that was
interesting was absolutely obstacles
ammonia money 2.2 - and we didn't get
enough data to see if that significant
some more testing should be done to see
like what happened if that's actually
something that's less polluted I guess
and so then we had like we collected all
this invertebrates and we can put it on
a PI track but we wanted to figure out a
way to what does this mean how can we
compare these two like okay like D
wonderful has all these species and we
don't need and do you want oh we only
had like this one species of
invertebrates like how can we compare
these two so we decided to do diversity
indices and one of them was the Simpsons
index so you looked at dancing pool
dancing alone and the entire dam stood
system and upstream system and our
conclusions were downstream pools were
more diverse than the Falls and dance
and so and downstream in general was
more diverse than upstream and then we
did another diversity index called
Shannon Boehner and so essentially be
looking at H and this one kind of said
the opposite thing it said downstream
baffles are more more diverse than cool
than upstream is more diverse than
downstream and I think I respect that
it's probably because of how they're
calculated if you know it's in the
denominator first
that's it kind of doesn't give us much a
way to if you found one species that
would be one one minus one which would
make the denominator Oh sir I think I
suspect that that's probably why aren't
you indices don't agree on that friend
and then I turned it over to thanks for
all right so I reviewed some research
that might be important to consider for
like training so the paper that I
reviewed was amended community theory
includes restoration by Christopher Swan
and Brian L brown medic community theory
considers local and regional effects and
how varying the agreement of isolation
along our network such as a river can
change these effects so Swan and Brown
used the metal community theory in their
studying of or stored and unrestored
streams to determine how the determining
how local and regional effects can
affect the success of restoration so in
order to determine the isolation of
particular points along a river network
they use this trailer stream order
method of classification so this is a
just a little picture depicting the
basics of Strahler stream order
classification so you can see that a
first-order stream to first story
streams come together to form a
second-order stream and that's the two
second-order streams come together to
form a third okra string I said a
first-order stream cannot come together
with
during the May 3rd overstream there must
be two secondary streams to become a
third over stream so Swan Brown found
that in first first and second order
streams were classified as isolated
headwaters and third and fourth order
streams work classified as main stem
wires so Swan and Brown found that in
these well-connected main stem reaches
regional effects were more likely to
play a role in biodiversity of benthic
invertebrates
whereas in isolated headwaters local
effects were more likely to play a role
in the vibe of this video Annika
Bergeron so so what does this mean for
Lake Tremont Lake treeman or the stream
that became lake Sherman was determined
to be a third order stream so what this
indicates is is that regional effects
can potentially play a larger role in
determining the biodiversity of our site
and local effects so the dam at Lake
treeman could potentially be impeding
species dispersal at our site so if we
potentially removed it in the damn it
could potentially increase the
biodiversity of our site and one final
thing that's one Brown in an effort to
bring out in this study is that sites
like Wade Tremont should and could be
could and should be researched to
further restoration ecology
understanding of how local and
sex effect restoration and how we can
better restore the sites like lake
treatment and now we'll move on to Ryan
and the bacterial contamination ops so
relating to the ethnic diversity and
overall human health we want to
investigate in certain types of
contamination such as eco contamination
don't you do that we collected six
samples along along the water jet like
this example on the watershed jiancheng
upstream to downstream then we took them
back to the lab and we do desperate for
the contamination we we use this
quantity tray system which is
essentially trays for each sample you
fill it with other metal of water sample
at least with reagent and incubated for
24 hours and then if it worked at the
e.coli or any other coliform bacteria
we're looking for is present it will
interact with the reagent and then it we
should go over a blacklight so that's
the example so these are some pictures
on our collection various sites and this
is all of the samples lined up and as
you can see there's a gradient of
contamination so if we want at the end
of the glow these are depositing at the
sediment deposits deposits the
contamination and this is a concern
because as you can see the swimming
areas or this hume interaction with the
water is very effeminate it's
effectively possible concern for human
health and then just as a conclusion
this is sort this is sort of hinting out
hinting that there needs to be more
research done just words and
contamination is coming from and if it's
like a human source or if it's from
livestock we really need to like locate
in
these contamination points to prevent it
in the future to protect human health
and just the overall health of our
system
so during my project we also did
vegetation analysis and we have three
main objectives we wanted to identify
the diversity with within and around the
marsh we wanted to identify the main
cover types within the marsh and we also
wanted to identify where the invasive
species are because I know that's a big
priority for the state parks Burgers so
the way we did this is we had 21 sites
that we did a drone flyover as you saw
at the beginning of the video and at
each of these sites we collected
representative samples of soil and
vegetation and these are just a couple
photos of us in the field doing these
field sites after we collected all these
samples we went up to the Bayley aureum
and worked with Ana Stelter who very
kindly helped us identify all of our
samples we also did nested quadrats
downstream of the marsh and this showed
us that there's about 33 species in a
six meter squared radius which defines
the understory in this forest below the
marsh we also do variable tree radius
plots and we found a total of eleven
tree species this sounds pretty low but
it makes sense because they're woody
species as opposed to herbaceous species
as we did in the nested quadrats so from
this we calculated the percent dominance
for each species and the trees per acre
for each species so our parks cares
about the most is probably invasive
species so we identified all the
different regions where invasive species
were found in the marsh and we have
Japanese knotweed we have reed
canarygrass
and we know Craig my tease I'd like to
point out that Phragmites is pretty
centralized in a localized region but
the reed canarygrass and Japanese
knotweed are spreading through
the marsh which might be a big issue so
these are the three invasive species
were focusing on fallopian japonica
which is the Japanese knotweed
Phragmites Australis which is Phragmites
and then phalaris r-run de valència
which is great canary grass we also
looked at the diversity in and
throughout the marsh as well as
downstream and when you first look at
this mark surely it's just a bunch of
cattails what's going on in there but in
reality we found 66 different generals
of different plant species in there and
it actually equated out to about 90
species and we still had some unknown so
it's probably closer to a hundred
species downstream and our nested
quadrats we have 33 species as I
previously mentioned and 11 species in
the variable tree radius clause and I
also would like to point out that as
you're going from the inlet of the
wetland down towards the dam diversity
is decreasing as you're going down on
which you know you might impact the
vegetative impact on this field site we
also realized that some trees are
starting to to assist in in succession
of this Marsh so the tree species that
we found are platanus occidentalis which
this american second one and eastern
agudo which is boxelder so most of this
trees we found of a Serna Gunda were
just little seedlings but there were a
couple mature trees so we took a corn
from one of the mature trees and it aged
out about 20 years so this just
demonstrates that succession is not an
immediate process it's not going to fix
our problems as quickly as we would hope
so
we might suggest planting some
species to try and help stabilize the
banks with the roots or also shade out
some of the invasives that I previously
mentioned now this is where it starts
getting interesting when we first
visited our field site we saw this big
empty field of where there used to be
Japanese knotweed and we found out
viewers actually had created a knotweed
dam using all this stuff and fit down
you know that sounds pretty crazy but it
gets crazier this knotweed that these
beavers are cutting down are actually
water routing and the beavers are acting
as a vector so this is them actively
spreading and invasive species which
might have a larger impact not only on
our site but also throughout the county
so the state might want to look into
this a bit more because it's obviously a
big problem we also when we were going
through all our drone photos we found
this interesting thing happening we
found some Carrick's
which is such just in the middle of all
these cattails and it's kind of
interesting we're thinking this might be
a native sedge so it would be good if
you plan on replanting in this marsh to
use this because it's obviously I'm
competing type ovitch it's a large
dominant in this field site and it's
also low growing so it's not going to be
taking over too many other habitats for
other species when we were doing our
variable tree radius plots we found a
ground cedar which is a club moss and
it's actually a state protected plant in
New York State so if the state needs
some interesting aspect to you know
really sell to whoever they're working
for like this is an important site we
need to focus on this is one aspect you
can go at so in conclusion we just want
to recommend a couple things from the
vegetation aspect the state my
want to do more fall and spring sampling
of vegetation we were very limited for
this because we only had this fall
semester to do this but there's many
spring ephemeral and public plants that
I'm sure we missed
we also suggest doing more upstream
nested quadrats and variable radius Lots
just to get a better understanding of
what's going on
definitely studying the impacts beavers
are having all these invasives possibly
getting more funding for the knotweed
and we believe it's coming from an
upstream store source but we're not
really sure
using Watkins Glen as a reference site
you'll go into more detail about that
very soon in this presentation and
possibly identifying some important
wildlife habitat we found some different
species like wood ducks and black birds
when we were doing our fieldwork so now
I'm going to turn it over to Karen and
Daniel for soil analysis
okay last but not least we're going to
talk about the soil analysis that we did
on this site and we are trying to answer
two primary questions one being are
there any issues with the soil that can
limit the plantings and recommendations
we have and also if we were to remove
sediment from the lake is the dress
material hazardous and if so what can we
do with it and answer these questions
we're looking at both surface soil
content around lick treatment and
upstream and the dredge material that
was mentioned earlier in this
presentation but surface soil we looked
at aggregate stability texture active
carbonate nutrients and with the dredge
material we're looking at heavy metals
and soluble salt and our additional
challenge was to do all these tests on a
small class budget but luckily the
Cornell Saarland Health lab was really
generous and allowed us to do a lot of
these tests ourselves for free and then
be strategic about what tests we
submitted on to do we looked at 25
different heavy metals some of which are
shown in this chart with our five drug
samples and the list of heavy metals and
what we found is that the majority of
the heavy metals are pretty far below
the level of concern that New York State
has so that's good there were slightly
elevated levels of nickel and zinc you
can see the yellow highlighted parts
there with the truth or drug sample one
in two but both were within what we call
the raw background soil level that's
what you might naturally find in upstate
New York oils and they were also pretty
far below the level of concern for
Public Health and aquatic health so they
are things to keep an eye for and if you
do plan on dredging or removing sediment
we would recommend taking more samples
of sediment from the lake that could be
dredged core samples or water samples
just to verify that these numbers do
represent the heavy metal content in
light treatment and then also
acknowledging that if you
resentment and moving it elsewhere with
the place with high thing or nickel
levels and that could be a problem but
overall we decided that the sediment was
generally suitable for any uses and that
there's not any problems right now for
public health or ecological health and
then here we just have a map of the
relative concentrations of nickel is
sampled in like treeman and we
especially want to show this because
this was pretty prevalent throughout all
of the heavy metals where you find the
highest concentration closer to the dam
further downstream kind of similar to
what the methane hume was talking about
earlier so that's probably where you
would be removing sediment but it's
important to acknowledge that this is
also where you might have a heavier
concentration of heavy metals because of
the finer soils and that's just where
sediment is accumulating when we're
drying out our samples we start to
notice these crazy salt formations so
we're like we're gonna look into soluble
salts but luckily all the samples are
pretty non saline are only very slightly
saline which means that the sediment
should be generally safe for any plans
for treatment or treat you want to add
and then moving on to the surface
toilets we want to look at aggregate
stability and so this is how well so
aggregates aggregates resist falling
apart when they're hit by heavy rains
and you measure it by sifting out
argit's of a certain size putting it on
a cyst and then putting it under this
crazy machine the Cornell sprinkle
infiltrometer which kind of simulates
when a standard or any policy for five
minutes and then all the stuff you have
left is your stable aggregates and use
that to calculate ear aggregate
stability and here we have a turn of our
results and I tried always used to score
those results and overall we found that
our
without creating medium to high IV
instability these might be slightly
overestimated because we had a heavy
sand content but in all this suggests
that there's a pretty strong resistance
to soil loss during rain events so this
is pretty good for the site good for
plantings and annual is going to talk
about the rest of our soil analysis
instead of behind behind there you go
great thank you so it's first texture
many of the soils on this site scored
similarly much of our sand content was
up here between 90% and 60% so a lot of
very well-drained soils heavy sand some
of this can have to do with some of our
sampling methodology if we went back and
had a chance to do this again we would
be taking much deeper samples to get at
not just what's left on top but some of
the smaller particulates underneath the
active carbon this is an interesting
measure so when you consider the
rhizosphere all of the bacteria that are
down in the roots of trying to help the
plants and trees establish they need
active carbon for functioning and this
test uses an interesting oxidative
reaction to determine how much carbon
not just rate carbon there but how much
is actually going to be available for
reacting we found that intuitively given
the heavy sand content there wasn't a
whole lot of active carbon in these
samples the sites that showed the
highest concentrations 7 8 11 18 these
areas that either had standing water or
areas that were prone to deposition
during
additionally there's a gradient as one
moves through the wetland if we have
been oriented here there's the the inlet
over here on the left and the dam
reservoir down here in the bottom so
again that's that's flow slows down
you're going to find a particle
deposition and that would help
facilitate increased active carbon again
soil health lab at Cornell excellent
total framing the home garden to 1060
soil nutrient analysis generally it's is
going to be used for agriculture problem
solving do you have an individual
mineral or element that your soils
lacking in so we use this to try and
figure out like is there anything on
site that is going to derail future
plant events or are there pH concerns
that might help us do we shift towards
an air cassius replanting skiing or
something a little bit more alkaline
living as far as the nutrient analysis
really not a whole lot to say nothing is
too high nothing is too low the soil
will be really facilitate new plant
establishment looking at pH so generally
pH is going to have this step like a
round seven moving neutral the soils
that we have on site are just above
seven so we're going to be in that
slightly alkaline range so we're not
going to be planting ericaceous things
that moral is that kind of stuff but
generally there shouldn't be a big issue
with species selection from a pH
perspective additionally we have the
organic matter
again intuitively hi Sam content
well-drained soil there's giving me a
low organic matter a lot of soils range
from one to six percent usually one
won't see these below one percentages
and set for a desert soils so that's
sort of what's being created there is an
interesting little microbiome where the
sand or all the organic matter washes
off and
sois here we can see it again these
areas that have well seven eight eleven
this is a beaver dam area there's also a
flood deposition in that spot so fairly
high om there and then framing it all
together what we tested of the dredge
samples didn't throw back a lot of red
flecks however using a neck wound wrench
which is a quad that goes down and
samples the top couple centimeters of
soil that lets us know recently what has
happened now what happened in the 60s or
the 50s during any kind of development
in the area we don't know so one of the
ways to get at that would be to do cores
and test various layers of those course
beyond that there are almost no concerns
when it comes to plant establishment
many things should do well on this site
there will be a break-even of course of
closer to the water rank sandier soils
you're gonna have things that establish
more easily but it really shouldn't be a
problem for the site this is a great
resource it can be available digitally
we used the entire way through doing our
event not standard operating procedures
through our interpretation of data so
whether at work or at home is unique to
you so I was like that's the best this
resource I'm Ann Arbor stood botanic
garden and this is likely a
self-indulgence is if I don't talk about
trees for one presentation I've probably
done something
as far as replanting there could be a
lot of things accomplished by that some
of it could be stream bank stabilization
like we're seeing these will is down on
the bottom right it could also be
invasive competition strategies a lot of
the invasives on site probably a full
Sun and organisms if you can establish
some kind of successional solar barrier
above them and that might be a
mechanical free chemical for a method
for treating it but over a very long
term to that end some of the species on
site that are already doing that you can
see here this isn't like treatment but
it's what it could look like with a
bunch of red stem dogwood a lot willows
establishing on the banks they're doing
great willows and poplars especially
right in those sites and then largest
trees on the site right now are the
American settlers for some species
diversity I'm a big fan of deciduous
conifers taxodium the bald cypress is
very common in these kind of habitats
and they will out-compete many other
woody species given the section strings
if you want to get fun I really like to
Mexico it was one of the most common
wetland tree species on the North
American continent
I've been till about two and a half
million years ago they do ma petites the
kind of site here we can see this is a
stream and these trees have roots right
in the stream so it could be an
interesting
woody addition to any kind of replanting
strategy if you consider that a lot of
the downstream and current site draws
are an element of tourism or an element
of that ecological experience or novelty
when it comes to rhetoric another
interesting native tree Kentucky coffee
tree there they have lost their
evolutionary seed spreaders whenever the
large arthropods
excuse me large herbivores left the
continent so you're only going to find
this tree where it seeds just to be able
long streams but again very competitive
in saturated soils it would establish
well additionally it's a colony forming
tree if you keep the Beavers on site and
they mow a tree like this down it will
just come back from the roots and yeah
final concern the Beavers it's it's easy
to say I just removed them but they do
do a lot of the things that one might be
trying to accomplish and a wetland
maintenance or what the restoration
thing they build dams a slow flow they
retain sediment they also eat all the
trees that you try to plant and as we've
seen earlier they do have potential
vectoring of the not lead
so in summary we looked at as many
things as we could on site and try to
get physiological characteristics
getting environmental issues and looking
at the biotic systems one really
important ecosystem service clearly is
that there is sediment being retained as
a sediment that isn't going into
Buttermilk Falls as a sediment that
isn't it making it into the inlet or
into the lake so this is a really
powerful Rachel benefit for a lot of
shareholders as far as invasives
there's always this dichotomy invasives
bad natives good though it comes to a
large site restoration we've seen these
invasive do some potentially positive
ecosystem services phalaris
is retaining soil all along thanks Wow
there is that woody transition so do we
immediately remove a flare so can we
focus on some of the other things like
the Franklin's and again should the
beavers go it's would be really
interesting to track some of those cut
water it in sections of not only and see
where they're ending up and are they
establishing on the bank as they get
through snow away
we have a little bit before big
decisions have to be made provided to
damn continue standing again about 30
years before this will entirely fill up
and we'll lose some of those sediment
retention ecosystem services on the
other side removal of the dam could be
really important when it comes to so
arthropods are other benthic
invertebrates who use that waterway to
travel up and down as far as gathering
more information there's a lot of
resources locally to us one that we
advocate for and that we refer to a
couple times is the Watkins website they
have a couple of big dams one of them
now is just a successional forest and
and the other still has that wetland or
lake feature so it would be interesting
to determine here's what we want to see
in the future for Lake treatment and
then go to these sites and see how those
sites either accommodate or mitigate
reaching those goals and finally I'll
turn it over
so we had we just want to thank all the
people that facilitated us completing
our project we couldn't do it alone we
needed the help of experts to kind of
help us interpret and even do some of
the things we've done in this project so
like thank you all and thank you guys
for being here
and so we threw a lot of information at
you and you probably need some time to
digest but you'll have questions so
these are a few resources you can reach
out to before we publish our report so
yeah these are some cool all right so
thank you guys and if you have any
questions now's the time and we can
direct it right individual people
specific groups like I've been doing
quite a bit of work on sediment
transport and especially long six-mile
Creek and I have some problems with just
looking at off stream sources of
sediment coming into the lake and not
looking at the possibility of in-stream
sources in six-mile and I think in some
of the other creeks on here but I
haven't got the data we've had a period
of stream degradation for about the last
50 years that means the stream has been
cutting its way down and that's because
the land use has changed I mean
originally when everything is forested
around here the relative input of
sediment from the uplands and off stream
sources was low and we had narrow
channel Dwight and meandering strings
but when always DeForest didn't turn in
agriculture had tremendous input offset
Ostrom sediment which caused this James
to upgrade fill in and become multi
channel on all this concept and it's I
didn't make that up there people people
are quite aware of that but you know the
area's become reforested now so what
does that mean that means there's less
sediment in general coming in from all
stream so what's that mean for the
stream well the stream had become it
tried to get an equilibrium with this
tremendous amount of sediment coming in
which meant it had more energy and now
it has this energy but it doesn't have
any sediment because there's a balance
between energy and sediment and so
what's the stream doing is removing that
sediment that it has been stored in
there and six-mile a lot of internal
crossroad and I've been monitoring the
stream channel there since nineteen just
after agnes 1972 when we moved in and it
says you know not believe this but that
stream channel has degraded about 14
feet over that period of time it's
they've stabilized it now so that I
can't measurements making it so I think
it's really important to get some
measurements in upstream in buttermilk
upstream especially not in the gorge
area or a comfortable comfort anyway
thankful that area but up above that the
stream is out of the bedrock and so
there it's capable of being degraded and
it could very well be like six mile that
a very large fraction of the sediment
that's coming into like streaming isn't
from those I'm monitoring to defend
agricultural procedures but it isn't
coming from those agricultural lands
it's coming from in-stream degradation
are you yeah
yeah so the point of identifying mirrors
and hot spots was basically based on the
curb numbers in those areas so
interesting the permeability of soil in
there but the actual calculation for how
much sediment is being deposited is just
from an elevation so just how high the
sediment is now relative to what it was
like before the down the stairs go yeah
okay that's two different things you
mean you're gonna measure how much
sediment is being collected in them
behind the dam okay that's independent
of where it came from and all these soil
measurements and I get an argument with
Todd Walter sometimes enough talking
about this bit it really doesn't do a
good job in on determining how much
sediments coming from the stream banks
and extreme degradation you you have to
make some measurements and you know it
takes time but maybe there are some data
out there for instance not a nominee
bridges will cross but the county
engineers
at least in some bridges always measured
the depth of the channel or the water
surface I don't know but there's some
not the best data but there's some data
there that could be used to determine
whether or not there's significant
degradation going on upstream at
upstream
I have a question for the invasive
species team you looked carefully at
beaver and the potential impact that
they may be happening with Japanese
knotweed did you also look for evidence
of beer browsing and how that might be
impacting the species distribution we
like to call knotweed Islands that and
the judge show you where all the topic
was cut down by the viewers so there is
maybe some potentials for it here
here's also browsing and interfering
with some of the species composition
within the March but it's definitely
something we should look more into I
know we've seen deer and deer droppings
frequently as we hike that trail
just anecdotally up we have knotweed
problem and there's I don't give a damn
how much that beavers are exacerbating
that problem but it ain't gonna stop
every little piece of not week it comes
downstream it has the capability of
reroute and if if there's not weed
upstream sooner or later it's gonna be
not way downstream well I think that
same thinking about getting rid of
Beaver because they might be
transporting knotweed is not a I mean
maybe get rid of beaver for a different
reason but I don't think that's a reason
also get rid of that problem but just
you know trying to minimize the
the more complain more spread of it with
the Beavers also present on the site
we've been trying to get it we're not
wait it's it's almost impossible yeah
yeah I I certainly wish deer would eat
more of it Elliott in the springtime
they will need something that needs
another question this is a class project
and like every time I've offered this
class for the past 16 years we take on a
pro bono consulting project for a local
government or nonprofit and this fits
into that context very well where it
will go from here kind of remains to be
seen
I'll suggest as an example five years
ago we looked at Spencer Lake and
Spencer Lake has a low head dam shorter
dam not not as tall as this dam and the
Corps of Engineers and State Dec wanted
the dam removed it dated from the 1820s
and they were assuming that Spencer Lake
was 50 feet deep and that could pretty
much wipe out the down you know the
downtown portion of Spencer had this dam
failed so we did a lot of bad things
read down there and we found that yes
there are some I smell pockets there
that are 50 feet deep but upstream of
the dam there is a subsurface Ridge and
only about 30 centimeters of water over
that Ridge so should the dam break for
example the likelihood of 50 feet of
water times 29 acres blowing out the
town of Spencer were relatively small
well they have been the the state was
people who came to this presentation
that presentation very like that were
very they said huh who knew they have
still yet to figure out exactly what the
proper course of action should be and
you're sitting next to a former student
in this class who worked on the Spencer
Lake project and so as far as where it
will go this will inform state and local
and perhaps even federal authorities on
deciding where it should go you know
where they would like it to go but this
is a not exactly a one-off thing but it
is a class project and tomorrow is the
last day of the semester so we're not
kissing the project goodbye there will
be a report a technical report that will
hang out and continue to stimulate
discussion and hopefully inform
decisions and yes Jim yeah I would like
to say it build off that very much as a
representative of state parks we are I
think we got a ton out of this we have
we had worked with with Tom and with the
classes to trying to help inform a
resource management plan for that area
which is important for us and so we've
got representatives from our field team
here
planning Park operations and basis
patient invasive species as well as
educational department so we there's
stuff in here already I think we can we
can act on that some small-scale stuff
that's going to have some impact so we
feel like we've got a little bit of a
roadmap much greater understanding and
then as far as it did the dam go is it
also has some historical significance
artifact that the Civilian Conservation
Corps so we have several mandates that
we that were required to live up to and
having this information it's going to
really help us to do that so we're
looking forward to taking it yeah great
so are there other other questions or or
comments I just had a quick question for
the class amongst all of you if
anybody's strongly feel that should be
returned to a lake or somebody like no
one's gonna say a marsh it was very
debate about where it should go or what
it should be I think like the different
groups were like prioritizing different
aspects of the system so like it
performs like a variety of services but
like ideologically for instance it would
be nice if we could redirect flow and
like a little more flexibility but then
like the invasives think probably far
like trade-offs between like water lake
divers
I think overall we think that retaining
some aspect of the marsh is definitely
this by the way is another former
student in this class who thank you very
much for coming over here so in terms of
larger impact these guys do go out and
actually do things and I'd like to think
that in time and over the course of
their professional careers it does
influence the way they approach problems
and things like that so okay
thank you very much everyone and if you
want to ask additional questions I'm
sure the students would be eager and
available to answer those thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu